tout de suite décryptage analyse on va
plus loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec Marie Roger
Billois présidente du groupe africain
international bonjour Marie Roger
et Bruno Darroux chroniqueur
international ici même à France 24
bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël la Chine
c'est elle enfin résolue à vivre avec le
covid en réponse en tout cas au
manifestations qui ont secoué plusieurs
villes du pays Pékin renonce aux mesures
les plus drastiques de sa politique dite
de 0 covid en vigueur depuis 3 ans
écoutez la réaction d'un salarié chinois
il est employé d'une banque
notre vie notre travail vont être plus
facilement car nous n'avons plus besoin
de test covid négatif pour entrer dans
les immeubles de bureau cela signifie
que nous pouvons réduire drastiquement
le nombre de tests que l'on effectue ça
va nous faire économiser du temps voilà
cette chinoise donc employé de banque
qui se réjouissent c'était c'est
l'occasion aussi de s'en rendre compte à
Bruno la vie quotidienne des chinois
était devenue presque un enfer ah oui ça
fait deux ans que c'était un enfer
quasiment tous les jours pour sortir de
chez soi pour se déplacer pour aller
faire ses courses aller faire un test
PCR quasiment tous les jours parce que
c'était valable 48 heures parfois 72
heures et puis il y avait le fait d'être
contaminé même de manière insatomatique
voilà on était envoyé en centre de de
santé qui ressemblait un peu à des
centres de détention quand même entre
fermer on ne pouvait pas passer sa
convalescence chez soi donc bref tout ça
a fait d'ailleurs que il y a qu'un jour
il y a eu quand même des manifestations
dans plusieurs villes du pays notamment
à Shanghai par exemple et sur le moment
bon on a noté le côté un peu
ras-le-bol d'abord côté sanitaire mais
aussi le côté du coup un peu politique
critique de la politique zéro covid
suivi par le Parti communiste et par le
président chez gimping on savait pas
trop l'ampleur que ça avait on sait pas
parce que les chiffres sont difficiles
de les obtenir en Chine mais mais en
tout cas il y a quand même une évolution
c'est-à-dire que
le annonce après annonce finalement on
s'aperçoit que la Chine tenter de
renoncer à une bonne partie de sa
politique zéro covid parce qu'en plus de
l'enfermement dans ces centres lorsqu'on
était positif de ces confinements à
répétition là vous avez vu à grande
échelle dans des villes parfois pour un
ou deux cas on confiné des millions
d'habitants et puis des tests PCR
quasiment pour tout apprendre les
transports aller dans des parcs enfin
c'était devenu vraiment
omniprésent le moment était sans doute
venu parce que fin novembre les
exportations et les importations
chinoises d'ailleurs ont atteint un plus
bas leur plus forte chute en trois ans
cette politique elle a isolé la Chine du
reste du monde Marie Roger c'est sûr que
cette politique était une impasse on l'a
vu on l'a dit et il y a un point très
important que je viens de souligner pour
nous c'est que la vérité devenue un
enfer donc tout ce qui était
manifestation n'était pas idéologique
c'est tout simplement que les gens n'en
pouvaient plus et ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que
cette manifestation lorsqu'on parle de
la Chine bon on a tendance à avoir un
pays monolithique avec évidemment cette
répression et puis cette volonté de
contrôler et on a on oublie que c'est un
pays où il y a une longue tradition de
manifestation et que la plus importante
c'était pas tienne amen c'est la plus
célèbre et que ça commençait bon soumao
c'était assez réprimé c'était très très
difficile de
de brancher mais mais après sauf pour
manifester le nom de la Révolution
culturelle voilà pour soutenir la
révolution mais il y a eu des cas
célèbres je me souviens moi j'ai
rencontré en Allemagne en 2006 une
dissidente chinoise déjà ce qui était
sous Mao qui avait qui n'aimait pas
cette résolution à la Révolution
culturelle ou les se suicider finalement
mais bon il y avait déjà et après tu es
un amène il y a eu la joie quand même
rappeler ça parce que on a l'impression
que bon ça bouge pas beaucoup il y a eu
des manifestations encore plus violentes
déclenchées par la pollution de
l'insecte falungon et dans tout le pays
ça a duré un an donc là la différence
des gouverneurs de Provin sont même été
limogé dernièrement par le régime pour
avoir empêché des manifestants au nom du
covid de manifester sur des problèmes
qui étaient liés à la crise immobilière
autrement dit voilà on voulait même
pouvoir autoriser ces manifestants à
s'exprimer c'est pour ça qu'on a limogé
ces gouverneurs voilà choses à dire
c'est une espèce de soupape de sécurité
mais
je crois que ceux qui a changé
maintenant et le fait que si j'ai une
ping malgré son intronisation comme ça
peut être en difficulté de manière plus
structurelle c'est parce que à l'époque
de la révolution qui était on a
complètement supprimé ce qu'on appelle
la bourgeoisie maintenant il y a une
nuit de classe de 400 millions de gens
et quand toutes les milliers de classe à
un moment donné on veut plus de liberté
on veut pouvoir
décider aussi parce que la décision
politique etc donc ce qui s'est passé là
on impression que certains y voit autre
chose que juste un petit mécontentement
il y a une volonté de changer peut-être
une classe moyenne qui aspire un
semble-t-il à voyager si l'on en croit
les recherches de voyage sur
l'application
setrips qui ont explosé justement depuis
l'annonce de la levée de ces de ces
restrictions et pourtant Bruno il y a
quand même un vrai risque parce que
c'est restrictions n'existait pas pour
rien en Chine il y a un vrai risque
sanitaire aujourd'hui oui mais alors le
problème c'est qu'en fait la politique
zéro covid n'a pas produit tous les
effets escomptés par dessus le marché en
plus de toutes les confins
c'est-à-dire 5000 5000 morts officiels
peut-être 15000 si on multiplie dans les
plus alarmistes on est très loin de de
pays voilà comme les États-Unis le
Brésil on parle quand même du pays le
plus peuplé au monde la Chine oui oui
non non mais ça a eu son efficacité
quand il y avait pas trop de vaccins
mais là on était arrivé à un moment
finalement où ça n'empêchait pas les les
cadres partis malgré toutes ces mesures
absolument dracniques ou la Chine avait
à vaccin qui était pas super efficace ou
la vaccination n'était pas assez poussée
notamment chez les plus âgés donc bon il
y a eu un c'est c'est manifestations
visiblement quand même le pouvoir
politique à estimer qu'il fallait quand
même lâcher du lest parce que
socialement politiquement c'était
dangereux pour lui jamais oublier que
les régimes autoritaires ont l'air
toujours très puissant mais ils sont
quand même toujours assez faibles
c'est-à-dire qu'il suffit d'un gros
mouvement populaire on le voit en Iran
etc pour que tout ce qu'on imaginait
super puissant se révèle finalement
assez faible et comme chez jimping est
loin d'être un imbécile mais en fait au
moment où il y a les manifestations ce
qui attendait pas quand même il a quand
même visiblement donné des instructions
pour lâcher beaucoup de laisse alors
est-ce que ça va produire
une explosion épidémique des cas une
flambée épidémique effectivement on
verra bien dans le même temps d'ailleurs
les autorités sanitaires chinoises se
sont mises à expliquer que finalement le
variant au micro-ondes bon le plus
dangereux était passé comme un homme
bizarrement tout d'un coup tout allait
mieux et aussi ils ont relancé assez
fortement la politique de vaccination
notamment des personnes les plus âgées
oui parce que c'est une population qu'on
peut imaginer nettement moins immunisée
ne serait-ce que parce qu'effectivement
il y a beaucoup moins de brassage social
et puis et il y a aussi ce taux de
vaccination assez faible sur les
personnes âgées Marie Roger vacciner une
population rétive à la vaccination le
problème et aussi
et c'est bien on a bien vu c'est plus
avec une vaccin qui est montré ses
limites qui n'est pas très efficace pas
contre la mort en tout cas qui qui qui
réduit la morbidité très fortement quand
même du virus et empêche pas la
contamination ah non ah oui le 6
novembre est semble-t-il efficace à
trois doses
donc mais le le ce que j'entends dire
les médecins c'est que quand même cette
politique qui consistait à donc confiner
les gens de manière excessive en disant
parce qu'on veut zéro covid tu es
l'absuruité ça les fragilise tout parce
que ils sont pas à l'abri d'une vague
une vague qui peut avoir à parler d'ici
même après une drogue plus sérieuse et
plus dangereuse que ce qui voulait
éviter ça le souci et c'est
effectivement le risque pour la Chine on
suivra bien sûr l'évolution des chiffres
dans les prochaines semaines en Iran le
président ultra conservateur Ibrahim raï
il lui a remercié ce mercredi les
étudiants d'avoir je cite empêché que
les émeutes ne se propagent aux
universités des propos tenus dans
l'enceinte de l'université de Téhéran
alors que le pays célèbre ce mercredi
une journée des étudiants et le
commémore chaque année la mort s'était
en 1953 de trois étudiants tués par les
forces de sécurité du chat d'Iran en
tout cas ses paroles elles ne laissent
pas de surprendre lorsqu'on sait que ce
mouvement il est parti justement
notamment des universités écoutez
d'ailleurs les propos d'un étudiant à
cette occasion
depuis 80 jours que les manifestations
ont débuté en Iran depuis le premier
jour les universités et les étudiants
essayent de faire des actions
symboliques
d'augmenter ce mouvement pour que le feu
de cette révolution soit maintenu
les étudiants sont une partie très
importante de cette révolution
on peut même dire que les manifestations
sont partis des universités
et même si la sécurité a été extrêmement
renforcée dans les universités cela n'a
pas réussi il y a calmer les étudiants
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de force de l'ordre
elles sont rentrées dans les facultés et
elle porte des habits différentes pour
mieux se fondre dans la masse
malgré cela les étudiants n'ont pas peur
ils continuent de manifester et de se
rassembler
dans mon université attérant chaque jour
il y a des manifestations différentes
et réaliser de différentes manières
féliciter justement les étudiants
d'avoir évité que le mouvement de
s'étendent ou bien il tente au contraire
de renouer les liens bah écoutez là
aussi on peut dire que le régime se sent
menacés très sérieusement menacé parce
qu'on est quand même après de trois mois
de manifestations depuis l'arrestation
plus la mort de Marseille mini c'était
mi-septembre et il y a eu ces derniers
jours quand même quelques signaux qui
montraient
je sais pas si on peut dire une panique
mais en tout cas une tentative du régime
pour envoyer des signaux mais qui
finalement n'était pas super efficace
parce que visiblement il y a des
divisions au sein du au sein de
l'appareil dirigeant il y a eu notamment
ce week-end l'annonce de la suppression
de la police des mœurs par le
représentant de la situation judiciaire
le procureur général montaziri mais qui
n'a jamais été confirmé depuis par le
ministère de l'Intérieur donc on ne sait
pas ce que ça veut dire est-ce que
c'était un leurre est-ce que c'était
justement le signe de tension interne
assez vive et puis il y a aujourd'hui
après quand même trois jours de grève
générale il faut le rappeler
le président quand même racistique qui
se décide à aller finalement dans un
symbole de ces manifestations à
l'université bon et qui dit à l'évidence
une contre-vérité qui a pas de de
manifestation dans l'Universités que les
étudiants sont à la pointe du combat
depuis presque trois mois
il y a aussi les déclarations d'anciens
présidents mon aide ratami qui a été
président de 97 à 2005 était considéré
comme un réformateur qui a été de faire
pas mal de choses qui a été un peu mis
de côté mais qui restait quand même à
l'intérieur du régime et qui a dit
aujourd'hui que il fallait écouter quand
même les les les slogans des
manifestants y compris femmes vies
libertés c'était un beau slogan et que
la liberté et la sécurité n'était pas
obligé de s'opposer bon alors on sait
pas trop s'il dit ça pour critiquer le
régime en place ou si le régime
l'utilise pour servir un peu de
médiateur envers ces manifestants en
tout cas vous voyez tous ces signaux
montrent que le régime 1 ne sait plus
trop quoi faire parce que sa politique
de pure répression finalement ça ne
fonctionne pas et mais la répression
continue quand même il y a eu cinq
exécutions décidés aujourd'hui contre
des manifestants qui avait visiblement
tué un membre de la ministre bassidji et
puis voilà cette tentative de de renouer
le contact mais moi je pense que c'est
un peu trop tard et que ces manifestants
bah ils ont surtout envie de changer de
régime pour changer de vie
où va le mouvement en Iran Marie
enregistrer d'avoir une lecture claire
enfin en tout cas des signaux du régime
parce que pour ce qui est de la rue
voilà ça semble en tout cas sa volonté
semble clairement exprimer le pouvoir
iranien est très complexe en ce moment
je vois des parallèles à faire entre la
situation en Chine avec les mouvements
aussi qu'on a eu et l'Iran où on a des
régimes autoritaires qui sont rappelés à
leur devoir de base c'est-à-dire que les
politiques sont là pour régler problème
de des populations pour parler
simplement et veiller à leur
épanouissement organisé l'épanouissement
de la cité je sais pas mais et là on a
beaucoup des espèces de glacis pour les
raisons géopolitiques les on a beaucoup
senti ça même maintenant vous la
révolution est très très forte en ira
des gens se disent oui mais si on
manifeste trop fort et si le régime
tombe et qu'est-ce qui va venir après
les veulent qu'on soit faible voilà il y
avait toujours un peu ça derrière et et
la Chine aussi à cette histoire de
shooting ping est soutenu aussi parce
que il y a une guerre
déclarée par les États-Unis vous êtes
l'adversaire on aimerait votre
développement économique nous gêne etc
évidemment ça aussi d'un petit peu les
chinois mais à la fin à la fin de la
journée comme disait anglais
les gens ils veulent que
ce circulé voilà ils veulent de la
liberté ils veulent une forme de
bien-être que ces États autoritaires
pensent donc tu penses pouvoir se
dispenser parce qu'ils disent que nous
nous défendons face à l'Occident nous
devons donc face à ça mais il y a une
population qui à un moment donné il y a
plus d'idéologie il y a juste le besoin
de vivre correctement l'idéologie ne
suffit plus dans ces deux pays
aujourd'hui à tenir la société toujours
un peu dans une économie parfois de
rationnement ou de liberté contre voilà
justement pour le problème de ce régime
prioritaire ils savent très bien au fond
les dirigeants que ils se maintiennent
au pouvoir bon restreignant ou en
supprimant comme on voudra beaucoup de
liberté et par exemple dans le cas de la
Chine il y avait un espèce de d'accord
avec la population c'est-à-dire bon on
reste un peu vos libertés oui c'est un
pouvoir autoritaire mais on vous
garantit une prospérité économique
parlait pas de politique dans la rue
voilà vous me dites rien vous ne
critiquez pas le régime mais nous on
fera en sorte que vous viviez bien
justement et ça a fonctionné quand même
pendant pas mal d'années et là en fait
avec cette politique zéro covid en Chine
ça crée une situation économique où
cette fameuse middle classe commence à
se dire où sont les frais de prospérité
là on commence sérieusement à en manquer
et donc du coup le fait de pas avoir de
liberté tout d'un coup ça redevient
aussi important et en Iran c'est un peu
la même chose sauf que les choix
idéologiques du régime iranien notamment
sur le nucléaire iranien ont provoqué
des sanctions économiques qui en
quelques années ont fortement impacté
les conditions de vie de la population
qui là se dit bah en gros ras-le-bol et
là aussi pareil les questions de liberté
quand même
reviennent à la surface très fortement
la question c'est notamment la liberté
des femmes la question du port du voile
notamment alors que c'est un peu mieux
accepté finalement quand la situation
quand les les fruits de la prospérité
sont plutôt bien répartis dès qu'il y a
pas ça en fait dans les régimes
autoritaires et ben ça se fissure assez
vite quand même la fin d'une double
instrumentalisation le covid par la
Chine les sanctions par l'Iran oui enfin
la fin on a des pouvoirs qui ont cherché
à renforcer parce que beaucoup ont
attribués aussi au covid la un prétexte
pour le pouvoir chinois pour mettre en
oeuvre en fait des réformes qui sont la
reconnaissance faciale le suivi le voilà
le contrôle total de la de la population
et bah alors fini justement on sait pas
parce que dans le cas de la Chine moi je
considère que c'est une situation
beaucoup plus sérieuse que en Iran parce
que c'est justement cette nuit de classe
qui est capable de porter des réformes
ou faire aboutir des réformes et et à la
fois prendre le pouvoir ou l'exercer
après les révolutions
disparaissent dans le sable quand il y a
à la fois il n'y a que la classe
dirigeante autoritaire et pas on est
dans le cas avec de fortes diaspora à
l'étranger qui communiquent aussi avec
la population on imagine bien que ils
sont transformés aussi de la manière
dont vivent les les gens à l'extérieur
qui prend le relais non justement c'est
c'est sur place qu'il faut pouvoir
organiser une alternative et pour le
moment elle se dessine pas du tout on
voit
ceux qui portent maintenant c'est plus
fort du fruit c'est une lassitude face à
la violence ou donc le pouvoir a envie
de lâcher quelque chose mais mais
jusqu'où l'absence de leader
effectivement la pointée dans les
manifestations de Hong Kong aussi il y a
pas de leader on ira un problème pour le
mouvement au bout d'un moment c'est au
bout c'est oui c'est toujours un
problème quand il y a pas de traduction
politique d'un mouvement d'un leader qui
propose autre chose d'abord d'un produit
politique mais aussi d'un point de vue
économique sociétal etc parce que au
bout d'un moment malheureusement le
nombre ne suffit pas c'est un peu pareil
en Chine alors bon il y a quelques
dissidents mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas
de mouvement organisés ou le mouvement
ne crée pas en fait pour le moment de de
leader qui est donc un peu comme ça a
été le cas pendant la révolution au
début la Révolution il y avait pas
vraiment de leader mais il y a très vite
des figures qui ont émergé et qui ont un
carnet aucune figure on peut pas pointer
du doigte et on sait pas où on va merci
beaucoup Marie Roger billot merci
également Bruno darous c'était on va
plus loin retrouver nous dans trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal dans
Paris direct
[Musique]